étranger
puis-je vous aider
c'est très effrayant ce que vous devez
traverser Je ne suis pas content que vous vérifiiez
tout ce qui est bon allez-y et
utilisez votre prochaine série de pilules comme
vous l'aviez prévu et et  c'est
bientôt fini d'
accord
[Musique]
tu parles du site des plans
[Musique] les
gens ont peur de tout ce qu'ils ont
peur s'ils passent d'un état où
c'est illégal à un état où il est légal
qu'ils
soient arrêtés  et leur voiture
pourrait être fouillée pour des pilules, je veux dire qu'ils
ont peur de tout et on
commence à avoir l'impression de vivre dans un
État policier quand on parle aux gens dans
les États rouges parce qu'ils ont tellement peur
de la façon dont le test  reste positif pendant quatre
et parfois cinq semaines après avoir utilisé
les pilules mais je pense que vous remarquerez
que vous vous sentez de plus en
plus normal depuis Dobbs c'est
qu'il continue de grandir et de grandir
et de grandir surtout parce que plus d'états
adoptent des projets de loi pour le rendre illégal et
donc de plus en plus d'États sont maintenant
obligés de commander leurs pilules plus de voyages
et
donc ils n'ont pas besoin de nous
étrangers
[Musique] les
trois premières années de la hotline, nous avons eu
un ou deux appels  partout où quelqu'un
a utilisé ses pilules à environ 18 semaines maintenant, nous
recevons un appel comme ça une ou deux fois
par jour parfois et vous savez que c'est
quelqu'un qui est dans un état de panique totale
parce qu'il vient de donner naissance à un
fœtus reconnaissable et que le
cordon ombilical est  toujours là et ils ne savent pas
quoi faire et ils sanglotent et
vous savez que c'est
vraiment traumatisant pour les gens
qui vivent cette expérience
[Music]
étrangère
c'est juste exaspérant que quelqu'un
doive traverser ça  des choses que
n'importe qui est seul sans soins médicaux,
vous savez obtenir des pilules de n'importe où et
ensuite avoir une expérience vraiment effrayante par
eux-mêmes, cela ne devrait tout simplement pas
arriver
et donc
faire tout ce que je peux penser pour utiliser ma
voix en tant que médecin pour dire ceci  doit
changer
si vous n'avez pas eu assez de liquides